this week on the true jordi podcast
we have a man who was described as one
of the baddest men
in the country a hitman with his own
firm
and connections to some of the most
notorious killers this country has ever
seen
it's bobby cummins at one time one of
the most dangerous men in the country
who's been known to associate people
such as the craze
and uh do some pretty bad things me but
sitting looking at you now
you come across as a nice guy so i'm a
nice guy no it's one of those things
it's quite strange but um
after reading up on your life and
deciding to get you on the podcast i
realized that
people would love to hear your story
because we hear a lot about the era that
you come from
we've all seen the cray movies and the
documentaries about people like that and
you were associated with them
and it's romanticized and i think it
would be good for you to sort of
tell your story about what it was really
like back in those days well brian what
you've got to look at is people
that are glorifying it weren't even born
when we were doing it
so it's all hearsay and mate believe and
fantasy
the reality is a different ballgame to
what that life is
you know we had rules like if there was
a contract on you
i couldn't shoot you in front of your
wife and kids because i wouldn't want
that done on me
so if you did that then you got punished
so
and and it was about you know people say
you're underwhelming somewhere on the
piccadilly line between
islington and king's cross you know it
was firms
there was different firms which
specialized in different things
and it was just business i mean someone
called me a gangster once you know
and i didn't like that because i stuck a
gun in his mouth and educated him
but i wasn't one of them and that's a
noble way to give an education there
well
solve the problem you know first you
educate them if you can't educate them
you intimidate them
and if they still don't learn all of
that and try and shoot you which they
did on me
then you've got to eliminate them either
way you do it you know
it's been interesting to see how you
view things today because like where we
are
i mean there's murders left right and
center around where we're even doing
this podcast from right now
and it seems like people are just
running wild and it seems like back in
the day
you call it the firm it was organized it
was it was organized crime in the truest
sense of the world
guns are too easily available now you
can get a replica change the block and
you've got
you've got a gun so to get a gun in them
though you have to be well connected and
pretty
well know you because what we didn't
want was a lunatic running about
shooting people
innocent people because then the old
will come in i mean they didn't mind if
we shot each other
i mean it was one less to look for but
if you started out in innocent people
two three people you couldn't do you
couldn't do an innocent member of the
public
you couldn't do the media right and you
couldn't do old bill
because it would close everyone's
business up because they would come on
the manner flood the mountain with old
bill
and no one were doing any money and this
is what i tried to explain to people
i weren't a gangster never had been a
gangster i was a businessman whose
business was crime
and you know to me i didn't know what
straight go has done or
weren't interested in what they'd done
you know they lived their life they were
just part of a crowd in oxford street
i lived in amongst my own people and
it was that culture you knew the rules
so if you was going to do villainy
and you subscribed to that that world
and
you knew what was going to happen if you
rolled over them with a rat or anything
like that
so like can you tell us how you ended up
getting into that world in the first
place
yeah first off i mean my family were all
straight goers i read that about you
that's what surprised me because i kind
of thought your dad would have been that
way away no
there weren't no villa i was the one who
corrupted them all you know yeah yeah
because they'd never seen money like
that you know they they was all working
no bricklayers don't
well we were quite wealthy then when
they got my bankrupt and that's why i
didn't mind doing
bank school i thought you took it off of
that i'm taking it back you know it was
sort of
balancing up the scales a little bit and
and i liked doing it
so it was a thing but what really
happened i started i worked in a
shipping office
and that was you know when we were on
the subject i was
15 all right because i left school early
you know
and uh i went in shipping office i quite
liked it i worked on tower
you know so i used to sit there had me
lunch with all the other young kids who
had left school early because i've come
from poor family you know our irish
family of eight kids
so four boys four girls so we bought our
part if you want anything in life you've
got to go out and graph for it
so we were workers basically all my
family were workers
and i was walking through finsbury park
one day and it was a couple of kids i
knew from my old school and i was
messing about
and someone fired a starting pistol
and his two old bill in uniform from
stoke new england went over was pulling
them
and getting a bit heavy with them so me
being larry
i've always been larry oh and i went you
can't do that without a responsible
adult
being here and he went what are you a
lawyer you seem to know and when i know
me rights
you've been alright fair enough they
walked out of finlandsbury park come
back with a cut-throat rosa
threw it on the ground and when we just
see you throw that and nick me
right now remember i've got no film i'm
straight guarding
my old man comes down the law shop and
you know
my mom's broken down in tears this very
going family you know i don't want to
work my mum and dad
we were very close we still are a
close-knit family you know when you
first started interrupting me you only
first sort of thought to say this to
this police officer
was there something in because a lot of
people just wouldn't have said a thing
you know
would were you taught your rights by you
know your dad or someone
where did you pick that up well my
godfather was an illegal bookmaker in
the old days
so he used to tell me with the law you
know you if they pull you you say this
you know because he was a crook all
right and um
so i grew up in king's cross area it was
you know i'm not exactly
you know it's full of prostitutes and
drug there all sorts of things
it's different now though isn't it
because king's cross has been completely
gentrified yeah but you look at
islington yeah i mean it was a sort of
off a slam area
but now you've got over a million pound
to go and live in chapel street around
that area you know liver
used to be quite different notice so
what did it used to be like because i
think a lot of people
i when i first came to london it wasn't
like that sort of emotion
yeah well when we was kids you know we
used to go down king's cruise because
that by the nose round
the the carriages see whatever we could
nick because everyone was a thief or
they was
had a fiddle going so we'd all have a
little bit of bank gear or something
like that
and i mean even as a kid we had
we used to go and click newspapers on a
trolley you know paul carter trolley and
we sent
a fish and chip shop and that's where
the guy didn't pay us
and i picked up a dead cat from the from
the building site for
meant to throw it at him and it hit the
camera when it was friar
and he's freaked out close his shop down
and he went to see my day but my dad
also used to do be a knuckle fighting on
a sunday
he was a bit handy with his hands on a
sunday sunday
and when they bashed each other up we'd
sit outside the pub
door and they'd give us our christmas
lemonade and we used to like it when
they got pissed because when they got
pissed they couldn't throw the pennies
in the air
if they was really pissed sometimes
they'd be like two bobby there or
something like that so we'd have a right
load up and we'd go pictures
saturday morning pictures and all that
sort of thing and so i grew up in an
area where
really crime weren't seen as crime it
was survival
and everyone helped each other in that
area everyone left their door open
because we had one thing in common we
was all skinned
so no one's going to rub off for each
other and if you could go in anyone's
house sit down at the table
and don't have a meal and it was the
right there was no racism or nothing
like that it was all cosmopolitan people
you know you had italians there maltese
there
you know black people there there was no
none of that because we was all skinned
so we all looked after each other we
went to school together we grew up
and um it was a nice you know we could
play it on the street and there was none
of this worrying about your kids out on
the street
yeah so it was that sort of area you
know and people cared about each other
you know and the old girls if your mum
cooked a dinner if there was an old
lady on her own whose husband died
saying there was nothing to think or the
taking or a dinner in or inviting her in
it was
more of a community yeah yeah yeah you
got it right you got it
so you're in the cop shop now and
they've got you on a razer
charger or whatever and uh my old man's
walked in
and remember he just took straight gun
like that right yeah
he's walked and he went what's all this
about i wanted to fit up
he went he said you're fifteen
they fitting policeman don't do that
oh when i'm telling you they fitting me
up he went look your mother's
broken-hearted
he went they said to me you plea guilt
it's a ten bob fine
if you please not get what you're going
to bolster he said if that happens it
broke your mother's eye you said just go
in there
take the timber fine go hands up to it
take the temple fine
i'll pay it he said we walk away from it
so just to put it in perspective
boston was like youth offenders prison
yes and my dad weren't there
so my dad actually is i don't know how
much i could say but like he's
basically the place he went yeah it's
being exposed for like just basically
abusing kids
it was a brutal environment very brutal
right and they got away with it
you know and they got away but like when
i was in parkland but
we can go into that as we go you didn't
want to go there so i didn't want to go
there but well i didn't tell you true i
didn't give a monkey
because a lot of my pals was in there so
if i'm going there all it is is like
coming off the street and going in with
a load of my make sure i went to school
because they was all at it and doing
terrible things but i wasn't
and uh then like my mum was upset
and he pushed me into it can't just go
hands up so i went all right just to
you know so it didn't affect the family
but then i've gone back to work
and they've read it in a local paper and
i got fired
because you couldn't have a criminal
work record working in a shipping office
because of the invoices and all that
right and uh
your bosses yeah not there yeah
and then they went sorry bobby and i got
them well with them you know they were
nice people
they were straight guys but it was nice
people and i went home
and i sent me thanks a lot you know lost
the job
anymore i'll come and work me on the
building site well i mean i'm five foot
six more fat and a greasy chip
you know what i mean i wouldn't be a
good odd carrier you know what i mean so
i went no no no i made my own way
and i'd already been dabbling when i was
a kid i knew it was a power note i've
always been out word of honor
and uh i got mixed in with the boys who
was in the same boat as me had a
criminal record
and i was doing crazy stuff you know
really silly stuff like putting bricks
through windows and terrorizing
people but up until this point you'd
never done that so was there a part of
you that was like
well i've done i've got a record now so
who cares that's good i might as well
what went through my everyone i thought
if you're going to fit me up and make me
bad i'll show you how bad i can really
be
and i mean that the i was watching the
boys
and there was games then you know
different firms from the archway
ivory and all that we used to meet in a
little greek calf i know that cups of
tea a bit of toast you know whatever we
could have thought
and i'm sitting there and i'm watching
harry's going down and i thought you
ain't got chloe
you know you're not organized and i was
very good at organizing things you like
and i said well what we're going to do i
said all right
they said you're going to come in with
us i said yeah i'll come in with you i
said
but we do it my way and they went well
when we do it by the way and i went
first when we've got to do is get it
structured we got it organized you know
and we've got to take over these other
firms you can't have too many funds not
enough money in it for all of us we
gotta have it
you know and i was a bit ruthless that
way
and uh it was funny because people when
they mention my name years later they'll
think i'm six foot six and built like
him
now they have this shock in their life
when they see this little bald eddie guy
who plays their tv
and they're talking anyway and
i said no i said what we need is proper
weapons because we started having the
gang warfares
who was going out with bayonets and
hatchets and stuff like that and i
thought
so that i'm like rolling on the floor
and ruining my clothes
you know and when he was cutting him
just getting blood on your clothes so
your clothes was messed up you know i
really [__] up
and i thought no it cost a lot of money
it's easier to shoot them
right so at the age of 16. i got myself
a sawn off and it was 410 double barrel
and um sorry how did you go about
getting a sawn off at the age of well i
knew
i knew people that would bang banging
older ones than me right
and they'd seen me doing a lot of their
violence
so they knew you know i could handle a
thing
and i said one guy when i need a gun and
he went well i went i need a gun
when i paid for it you mean what i
thought i would have saw enough shotgun
but i won a 410
double barrel side by side not over and
under side by side naturally
and he went well what are you going to
do i said earn lots of money
and he went i'll get you by tonight so
i'll give him the money
i've got i went and a box of cartridges
because you know you have to work
who could have accomplished the gun so
um
he got me a box of cartridges and there
was a little bit of game warfare going
on
and i walked up the arch like that oh
they sent a message there and they were
they're going to cut me up and feed me
to the cats
who was there a little firm up the
archway how old are these firm
people are they similar to yours six
yeah 16 we have 16 17. you know were you
playing adults at this time or are you
would you say you're different to a
modern day teenager who you look at in
the street
there's no difference the only
difference now is drugs have
you know screwed up the discipline bit
if you like
and also you know the
how can i put it the lack of they talk
about respect and i have to tell them
when i go to schools and colleges
respects is when you respect someone
else and they're pleased to see you
respect ain't about you walk in a pub
and someone's crapping yourself in a
terrified so they're being nice to you
yeah you know there's a difference
so if you want respect you've got to
earn it the only way you earn it is by
treating ordinary people with respect
we feel as we all know each other we
know what we're capable of
and we know what each other's speciality
is so if i wanted
a bent car i know he was ringing motors
if i wanted a dodgy passport and i was
in the printing game and
so you all had your little specialist
fields and sometimes with interlock
and we say well we need this offer you
and they go well look we've got a
problem we need you to do this for us
what was your field um
well violence really right that's that's
yeah and that's what you were known for
well we was known for
you know armed robbery and all that but
and
you know we was i was very good at
negotiations
you know we could always make people say
our way of thinking that we was very
good you'd have a lot in common he made
he made them an offer they couldn't
refuse you got it you got it you know
when we used to deal with them i used to
sit there
and it's in my book i'm not gangster and
we used to sit when i used to say to
look no cards under the table
when you deal with us all the cards on
the table and i've put a pound coin on
the table will indemnate it with a pound
note
pound note on the table and a bullet and
i say if you work together with us and
play it straight we all learn lots of
those
i find that you're dipping the tool
you're [__] us about you'll get one
of those
or there's a third option you can get up
and walk away now we never met
so you choose what you want but no if
you do it the wrong way
one of them is going in the back of your
nut yeah so
it was that sort of thing people
understood each other you know we
weren't well you're not [__] around
at that no
no so and all also i'd let the guns off
so they knew
that i would be don't mind pulling the
trigger yeah and then i got older people
who thought oh that means a little bit
because i'm a young kid remember
you know i'm 16 i'm firing guns about
the place and they went hold up
we need to educate him get him in and
you know in case he does something crazy
and [__] up all their business
so um the older ones come to me and when
you know do you want to go on a bit of
work
maybe they're seeing a bit of promise in
you as well yeah yeah well not what it
was that was very slippery i was taking
a risk and i was thinking you know i
would do this bobby you know
go around see this schedule it took a
little bit and i don't stand a lot now
but in them days 500 quid was a lot i
don't the average man was only six
12 quid a week and like if you collect
it
we give you 10 percent it's classic tony
montana and scarface isn't it like you
get the
the little bull to do all your work for
you and we were jewish
i mean basically we was abused we was we
just told violence
terrible violence and they use that to
earn money and i sat down one day and i
thought hold on a minute i'm doing all
this
and you're driving about in a nice car
so i thought well i don't need you
i can do it on my own segment and you
would slash football yeah exactly yeah
so what i've done
i was working out and i went now we'd do
it around so that's when i got my own
little firmware put them together
and i went this is what we're going to
do because now i know where it works
they've educated me
so in there i know whatever you use them
oh yeah
because i didn't know how it worked so
obviously it worked you know and then
once i knew how it works i knew i didn't
need them
and if they come up against me i know
i'd shoot them so i was on a winner
anyway
they had everything let's get back to
where we work
we've fast-forwarded a little bit okay
you've got this gun yeah
what's the next the next thing was um
like we did a few armed robberies you
know and i was nicked where are you
robbing sorry because i know that there
are you know we tried to do
really balls up we tried to do a post
office round someone told me it was full
of money
and uh what it was they'd already
delivered the money
so i've stuck up an empty van right no
i'll tell you it's true
stuck up an empty vein mugged myself
right off so gone in there and i've got
i went to they give me a detention
center at the age of 16 for carrying the
possession
of someone a shotgun an armed robbery so
i went to a senior detention center
where they totally beat the crap out
brutalize you took terrible no it'd be
abused
right so they took you there and they
beat you up and i'll come out a bigger
[__] because i'm fit now i'm down the
gym i'm working out
yeah they used to meet your trainer yeah
25 25 laps around a football pitch and
all that nonsense
they've been good they beat you as well
from what i've been told my dad said
uh if you were the last guy or whatever
it did beat the crap out of the last
time
and if they had somebody couldn't make
it around the football pitch you'd
carry them yeah that's right all that
crap you know it was all from this army
very militant yeah yeah was that
something you because what
struck me was that actually you had
quite a sharp sense of justice yourself
to stop those policemen
and you resented the fact that you had
to do it so when you go there
i resent anyone who's in authority who
uses that authority to abuse others
right even today right that's what
avoids judges and
all that sort of thing the government
but in them days i thought
that ain't right and i thought if i
could get you out of here on my own i'd
smash you a piece of a baseball bat you
know
but they was in there games of them and
they'd pick on a young weak kid
and take liberties you know really take
liberties and they wouldn't do it
if they was outside of you so that
enraged me even more i thought
you pick your people because i hate
bullies you pick your people
who you're gonna terrorize there but
that taught me that as well the violence
had a voice
i thought so that's where the government
control people if you
do what we you know we don't want you to
do we can put you in a nasty prison
where people are going to take liberties
and um so when i come out of there
because i didn't drink i didn't smoke in
them though i always drink bitter lemon
and um my dad went well you know what
you're going to do now
but by this time i'm angry now because
i've seen all what's going on you know
and i thought i said i'm going to put it
back on him he went what i went i'm
going to put it back on him
what do you mean by that i went i'm
going to run my own business be a
successful man
i've never told him what i didn't mind
because he got paranoid over the gun
he went we're not ever done today i went
no no no it's sweet so i've got the fur
when we got out and i went now we'd do
it probably
and we did it properly and and i looked
at it and my dad
didn't realize he gave me a clue one day
he said to me
do you know old george over the road he
runs to the restaurant i said yeah so
then you
suds around the corner he said keep
putting bricks for his win his
insurance is going through the roof he
said you know he's going to be out of
business
now by this time i'm coming up 17 or 18.
and i went is that right i said how's it
work day because
i love people educating me i don't know
so all the education i've got
has been off other people right later on
in life i've read books and
done degrees and all that sort of thing
i was sitting here and like scheming i
was always a schemer
and i went so how many times the bricks
have to go through the window
before the insurance goes out you've
been well three times and his insurance
when i thought lovely
so what i did i went out i met therma
when i got a nice learner
and you had all the indian restaurants
just open up and the chinese and all
that
is this east london this is all in all
the way right north london
and i had a bit of a bad rep then
because people knew i was and there was
a phone
and so i've got the kids i went here do
you wanna rain said we'll cut the quid
and i went
yeah but what we i said what i want you
to do see them restaurants go and throw
bricks through their windows i said
have it on your toes so when they done
it the second time i'll let them do it
twice
when they've done it second time all you
know when it's terrible what's happening
you
i said we can stop we can protect you if
we can stop decepting it
i said you know you're going to lose
your insurance but we can give you a
good insurance that it don't come from
when you're in the first place because
you've got people sitting here because i
was always reasonable with them i said
you've got people saying how would you
feel if you're sitting there having
your chinese take one a brick off a
brick it's you and yet i wouldn't spare
for business about your reputation
well i can stop it i said well you know
put a little bit extra on the bill
when we come in we eat free right and
you give us a little
you know kick back and we make sure it
doesn't happen and it started working
like a treat
and then it happened there was kids that
was going to wear
our tailors and he used to do it on
their never never like they could pay
off each week but once they got the suit
they was on their toes so he had a big
load of debts and he told my dad you
know he said
you know murray and uh what they told me
i went really so i went i'll tell you
what they want no money off your murray
just give me a list of all your debts
where everyone said you're over who they
are where their address is i said and
whatever i'll collect
i said i'll take 25 percent off but you
make my suits
one every three weeks at one every three
months for nothing
still done so we've done that denny's
mate read the shoe shop done
and the business built well he was
earning more money for nothing
you know and we used to go around and
bash people up if they took liberties
with them
so people see was actually working for
our money we weren't just
promising them we was actually doing the
business and it was a business
and i saw nothing wrong you know because
i'm only dealing with rats who
taking liberties with people i'm not
hurting you some people you know and
they knew we know what was doing
so that started up a good business and
then it got
really heavy and we had the triads
okay that but that's a that's a whole
other level of that's serious
because really what you're doing is sort
of a monetized neighborhood watch
yeah yeah and then all right i like that
yeah
monetize neighborhood yeah i love that
that's a good expression
if anyone can make a t-shirt just as
monetize neighborhood watch i feel
what's really good about it people were
happy to see you
you know because like if there was
lyrics taken like there was in the fish
and chip shop
i took that very personal because first
off we had to deal with the triads
and when i never got it he made me laugh
when i got because he was expecting
someone like east sides right
so he sent this message down this
[__] and he said
i want to see bobby cummings and so
frank come in i mean you went
got a [__] wants to see you he said
they look
like an every little firm well i know
they're from the china sounds josh
bravin you that little mob
we've never dealt with them so did you
know anything about them at that point
about them because when i got done for
the murder well manslaughter yeah right
i went to prison so i met
the triads in it was done a load of
arrow in and double the tongue in there
and all
and then you had the mafia in there that
was done with a 15 million pound
bond swindle and so we all let together
and prison is the best place for
networking
that was the social media for you yeah
so what you're looking at
where and this used to make me laugh
about london gangs
and charlie richardson told me he said
you know where they were going wrong i
went i'll tell you where they're going
wrong
this was when he's banged up because he
was my best friend charlie he was the
one who got me out
charlie for those who don't know was
notorious yeah well they called him
uh gang boss at a torture gang in south
london he was my best friend i read
europe
at his funeral and um he was really a
beautiful man
very educated where the twins weren't
twins were thick
right but that's basically the way it's
been described to me before charlie was
the brain he was doing lung firms and
all that before anyone knew about it i
mean they even copied it and took it to
america
so anyway we um these [__] come down
and uh i'd already done
two turkish geezers for trying getting a
get one arrow in and trying to
get her on the game and they were just
straight people they worked on fish and
chip shop we knew him from kids and my
mum and dad used to go there
so you said done you already done them
um yeah do you mean you made them
disappear sort of thing
well they disappeared and they're what
happened what accordingly to everyone
yeah right accordingly to everyone that
i
went in there with a sawn off i'd rock
salt in one barrel
buckshot and buckshot in the other
walked into their little lockout where
they fixed cars
the one who was under the car was shot
him through the fire walked into the
office stuck the old gun with his
brother's head and when if you went off
the manor in 24 i was going to put it
through your enough
now this is what was said but they was
gone in 24 hours wasn't it that's funny
isn't it
and people said i mean standing joke was
when i went in the nightclub cut the
days later because i didn't all my phone
drunk but i didn't drink
and there was a funny guy in there it
was a cheeky side but i loved him
because he had a good sense of humor and
a very good driver absolutely brilliant
getaway driver
and he went all right bob i went all
right alan he went um
weird the turks are gone i went yeah so
bye you know
even we had you done it for a pack of
fishing kits what you would have done if
they give you a pickled onion everyone
first out laughing
and i went i went don't you know be
careful
and we had a little laugh over it you
know and uh but we cleared it up but
when did [__] come down that was a
different ball game
they pulled up in two cars and i knew
who they were because they said they're
saying saying about triads i went
this is heavy this is it's not like the
gangs where we've bashed
each other on cage you know these firm
are nasty bits of work
i still get guns out i said and we can't
see them so we met him at ivory corner
now you've got to imagine this it was
like saying from the 60s
woody's [__] got out and i'm sitting
in
an old vauxhall because we wanted one
that if i shoot somebody we could crush
your heart
i never drove a nice car to be shooting
and uh i'm looking at him and i thought
i can see he's got something under his
coat
i didn't worry because i've got a sauna
or front of mine so i've got another
this is true right you know them pilot
glasses
right he's got tinted pilot glasses on
he's got a beige overcoat over his
shoulders
and i couldn't take him seriously i
started laughing right it was safe from
my like 16th gangster movie
and i got out and uh even though
once it i went on bobby comics and he
looked me up
quite surprised and he went we're coming
on here we're going to sell hello in
right when you think so he went
yeah that's what we're going to do but
we give you some
money i went you're not selling that
[__] in my manner
i won't be don't have it on my manner
right
and he opened up his coat and he's
pulled out an axe
and he went we chopped people up and is
that right flung back the code pulled
out the song i went
i'll blow your [__] head off i don't
know about that i when they get back to
gerard street or whether you come on
when you come here again i'm going to
shoot you
right and everyone's going oh i went no
i'll shoot you i'll blow your face off
i've been
get in your car and go i'm not a good
boy so they've gone
now my phone's going to cause a war now
we've got it really honest
they never come back never never come
back
so that was sorted but then i got a bit
you got lucky there a bit didn't you
oh not me i mean if there can't be but
it's been full together
so at this point when you're pulling the
gun on this guy yeah it was
i would have shot him yeah i know you
know when you're done you'd already shot
people
yeah had you uh have you killed anyone
billy this point
yeah i've done the killing that you know
people say i've done a lot but
i'll tell you what if someone called
flew in that manner it would have been
mu given me it was
it got really out of proportion right
now all right so once people give that
reputation
to you yes you get the credit for
everything everything to say if someone
got carved out
while we come into the net firm done if
he got hit by a car even the road
traffic accident oh they've arranged it
which sort of helps but also hinders you
in a way because it does
because because the people the old bill
were looking at you but then the old
bill were weighing it up
right i mean they'd walk in a problem
we'd be sitting there and something
like might terrible about like a child
being abused or
or you know someone's a spate of
robberies on old people's homes where
they've been beaten
and they'd sit next to us in the pub and
be talking about
it and they'd go you know we think we're
going to have to bring every mob into
sort out this area it's getting too
high on crime rate well that weren't in
our interest even if he was a coyote he
was doing
you know selling bank gear or bouncing
checks we didn't want no one messing up
the business so it was in our interest
to find out who was doing it
educate them in the back of the van and
then let it go away
and it was in their business as well in
a way wasn't it of course because you're
doing a lot of the dirty work
why do you think they're setting their
problems though they knew what we were
doing
so you know there was a little bit and
they let us get away with that
sort of a good relationship in a way not
really i mean they used to walk in
and go hello mr cummings and i just go
yes hello
and i used to go we'll get you i'm going
to put you away for 30 years
they and i went you got me on one bank
and i got not guilt in the old bailey
because i'm an innocent man i don't do
nothing i'm a straight goer
you know i don't work in a pine strip i
had a pot you know we had a good front
point stripping factory and all that
yeah
and i said you know that's different i
said why that you know why don't you
leave us alone we're just trying to earn
a crust and he went yeah we know you
earn it
right so anyway so that was your jenko
business yes yeah
you know and i used to look at the old
people in the pub every sunday
my probably run the butcher shop like
you come to saturday night
and i used to go and say what you got
over and we used to get
the meat over jimmy carter with a boxer
at the fruit stalls
so what yeah so we made have a little
parcel carry a bag for all the elderly
people
used to buy them their first drink in
the pub no one took liberties you know
if they were a little short they could
have a little short but we bombed their
first drink
and i mean david said that the old
bayley they said you know we know
he was a naughty boy but he weren't a
bad boy you know and i always treat
people with respect you know i did
violence reliving i was brought up
probably i didn't do bad manners
you know and i don't like people with
bad manners you know there's no need for
it
and that's why you know we've got the
reputation of
we're serious but we're not rude people
it feels like um the difference between
today's generation and and that
generation is
like you had class you know what i mean
i think
you had you know we always dress nice i
mean even when i went on armed robberies
or
still doing that they were in the
business i always wore a thumb
you know and we were still getting from
the same guy now he's dead unfortunately
and nothing to do with me right but
usually we used to go
you know we used to go there we were we
were dressed smart
it used to be funny because you'd walk
in in a pub or yeah
mostly past walked in a pub with your
girlfriend or your wife
and the men had all go one side and the
girls all went the other side talking
about earrings and
cool knows what they talked about and
all the guys were talking about villainy
like
someone come in and go like i've got
these lovely fur coats i've had out of
the back of a lorry so
it would be like trading sessions good
fellas ask that isn't it reminds me of
the movie
um one thing we haven't really covered
yeah we don't need any specifics but
the first time you killed a guy um
allegedly allegedly i mean we're
for most people yeah like for me
personally
if i was to ever kill someone it would
happen
uh in a probably in a street fight most
likely
it would be a rage it'll be timber and
it would be one of those we
you start punching someone and you just
can't stop until when you start out of
it
so like a bin um and then afterwards
you know the guilt and the emotion and
all of that comes about and for me
someone who isn't
uh isn't wanting to do that and isn't
considering a career in that anytime
soon
um it would probably [__] me up for
quite a while
how did you deal with that the only time
i always
prided myself on clean bits work
whatever i'd done it was cleaned
right and it's cleaned properly and so
innocent
people didn't get it and the one thing i
have to live with for the rest of my
life was a robbery that went wrong when
someone chokes on a gag
and died now that was an innocent person
who weren't a villain
when we was having a gang warfare
warfares cutting each other and shooting
at each other and
some people died you know um
didn't matter it was it wasn't personal
and they were never personal you was
paid to do it or you know or you've done
it so you've used it
as something like the way a soldier
would go into war sort of thing in your
mind
yeah be treated as a profession yeah buy
this or die by this
but also you know what i say to these
young kids today
if once you pick up that and you're
known to pick up that once you get up
at all when people come looking for you
they come looking for you for a tool
and they're going to come with you with
a tool and you're 33 times more likely
to be a victim of violent crime than a
kid that don't carry one
i mean i've had bullets put bullets i've
been shot
they tried to assassinate me three times
driving along with blacks out you know
the lights off the car and flying it
through the window and all that going
and like there's loads of rumors put
about about me like that
someone got shot for a litter box
because he took a shot at me you know
three o'clock in the morning or bill
wrong as he come down the stairs
anything someone stuck a gun through the
left box and shot him in the fight
you know but straight away oh because
he's took a shot at me i'm
i might make you the guy who've done it
yeah right when you get shot please me
it makes your eyes well
right it hurts and so you know
if you people pay you to do it and the
reason people pay you to do violence
because what they're asking you for and
this is where a lot of people didn't get
it
they're asking you to do their jail
sentence because they ain't got the
bottle to do it yourself
so if they go to me shoot him i'm going
to think right if i shoot you
if i don't kill you if i shoot you i'm
looking at
when my reputation now probably lifed
off but in them days i'd been looking at
15 years
how much could i earn in 15 years right
even with remission so to me everything
was business
and i didn't feel nothing about it
yeah i watched one of your interviews
yeah i thought one thing i found really
interesting was the way you said that
they would
dehumanize the target and say they would
they wouldn't describe them as
a man with a wife and kids they'd say
we've got a rat if you
if you thought about people with family
and wives and kids and grandmother you
couldn't do it
right so what they do quite simply they
go
you're a neutral type of violence anyway
you've done that many of it
it don't matter you've got to sleep i'll
be like you don't you don't lay awake
thinking about this
you you once you do one half it doesn't
make too many i'll put it to you that
way all right
so it don't matter whether you're
cutting them shooting or whatever you're
doing if you're that type of person
all right so when they come and don't
know normally comes
the person won't come to yourself it
normally comes through someone else who
knows you
because they never meet you right a
person who knows them now you've
probably known
that person for three generations in
that family and you know
that if they get nicked they're not
going to roll over on you
all right so you trust that person so
don't go lightly on this guy shot in the
leg now
don't know if i liked him or didn't like
him if the money was right i'm going to
shoot him
but if i started thinking about he's got
a wife who's had kids
i'm going to think about that and i
wouldn't be able to do it so what they
do they humanize that person they say
look we've got a rat here so when you've
got a rat
you're not getting rid of a person or in
a person what you're getting rid of is
vermin
you know and that's how you look at it
that's the only way you can do it
one thing that strikes me about that is
you don't know
do do you know the reason that person
wants that person shot in the leg
does that matter to you because surely
you have your own interesting no
no you find out what that person's on
when
when you're like if you're a hitman you
watch that person you
basically stalk them what they do where
they go where they drink who their pals
are because you don't want to be talking
to one of their pals is going to mark
their card
right so and then you find a place where
you isolate
and then you can do the execution or hit
as people call it you know if you're
that type of person
or if it's an eco job you know you you
target them so you know exactly what
time where they go what they're doing
i mean some of them we even went safari
if they're going to really whack you
they'll find out your medical records as
you've got diabetes because you can
shoot them up with insulin or
is your junkie so you can make it look
like an accident right better if you can
make it look like an accident no one's
screaming i've seen you on a
documentary i think it might have been
used a clip of you might have used in
the
jill dandel um that's right talk and i
found it interesting because um
you were talking about how you can make
a killing look different
what the reality is this right there's
two types there's one
that you do that's a public shooting
where you're sending a message out to a
firm a load of people
right and there's also the executives
do you mean just in broad daylight in
broad daylight yeah right you drive by
the car
and you're gone or a motor cycle could
you see there on a motorcycle
that way you know i don't like
motorcycles your legs are too big and
you get ran by a car
yeah and lose a leg so i always liked my
solid lumps of metal around me um
but you look at it and you think like
what is it so it's a public one
it's very where you're going to kill
someone in public you've got to be a
lunatic
right but you could do like shooting in
the leg or
jump out with ratchets and go to work
with them like with a nature as long as
you didn't kill them you know put them
in the intensive care for a little while
and you know give them time to think it
over you know
but and then you can have the
the one that if you like make it look
innocent or do it publicly where you got
to do an execution
and like kirk off when he got done with
the umbrella the russians were brilliant
and they are brilliant at poisons
right so different people have different
methods but if you're going into that
world
what you've got to do is you've got to
be able to change your motorcycle
so if you're known for using a blade
you've got to learn how to use a gun and
if you're knowing that about again
you've got to learn how to use poisons
and you've got to know how to make bombs
now the greatest place to learn all that
is in maximum security prison
because you're in there with terrorists
and you they know how to make bombs
right and you're in there with drug
dealers until your leave will overdose
or whatever
so you if you're that way orientated
you've got the network
to be able to do that but the thing is
you've got to live with that and what
you've got to live with
you might be the most popular person in
the crowd
you know because you're you're on the
firm you're one of the firm
but you're the loneliest guy in the
world because you don't know if
someone's your friend or if they're your
enemy whether they're plotting up to
everything you don't know why they're
around you no no
because you might have done too many and
someone thinks he's a liability now he's
got to go
so you've got to take that into account
also there's reward money
right if you've done banks and that sort
of thing with someone his girlfriend
says oh
he looks loved in it he's always
smarting his suit you know they've
always got money he gets the amp
picks up the phone clips the reward so
you
you're into you're you're watching your
own people you're watching the old bill
you know and the odd nut or you might
think well if i shoot him i'll get a
good reputation
or stab him so it's a it's a nightmare
world
and you know other people go to sleep
with a dream under their pillow i want
to sleep with a gun under mine
and you have to worry about petrol bombs
coming through your windows and
it won't so when people write these
stories about
oh how glamorous it was and i hate
people when they become experts
like you get these social workers
psychologists and all this [__]
that they talk about right and i think
you read a book about my life
right and then you become an expert on
it if you want to become an expert on it
come and live my life and do the amount
of bird i've done 13 years
in maximum securities where people
getting stabbed though to death over an
onion
you know because it makes me like old
prisons and already came from knows what
the lady came today ago
but where are when they were slashing
their wrists hanging here itself and
getting stabbed to death
you know so it ain't a nice place and
also about the crate
you're living in your toilet in a cell
right you're
living next to a toilet nothing
glamorous in that and it don't smell
like chanel
right you're living in your car zone it
starts with a sh yeah yeah
yeah you've got it in one right so
you're in there and you're surrounded by
people
especially in maximum security like
parker's britain's alcatraz surrounded
by water
and all the most dangerous was put in
there so you're seeing it and everyone's
a potential killer so
it was the most politest place i ever
was in my life because if you forgot to
say good morning to someone
they'd get paranoid think you're
plotting up on them and then they're put
up on you and appear in prison stuff for
paranoia
right everyone's paranoid yeah when you
were describing your lifestyle there
about how you didn't know what people
were going to do
and yeah obviously the closest uh i mean
don't get me wrong i know my dad was
mixed up in a lot of [__] and he had me
in prison but uh
i didn't live that life but i do you
watch the tv series like the sopranos
for example you see like
tony's problem people like how paranoid
they see me getting and you can only
imagine
really i'll tell you there was one come
out and it was really close home and i
did
the thing for an australian spark tv i
had to
view the film the pink panther right
yeah
because i was doing robberies all over
still up
right doing it all over the place and i
went i really did bobby and i tell you
what forget
i don't know ocean's 11 and that was
nearly near enough ocean's 11 but
you know lock stock and two smoking
barrels and all that absolutely
i'll tell you what i was sitting there
and saying laughing my head off this
comedy series yeah
it's a fast in a while i thought myself
were you taking a piss or what you know
and i was rolling about and my wife was
she was laughing about i went if only it
was
like that i went i said no and she went
hey exactly what you said she said how
do you feel when you did that sort of
thing for a living
i said to be honest with you i said i
didn't feel nothing
i'm not psychopath i just i couldn't
allow myself
to feel anything otherwise i would have
put one in me own it
yes it's amazing i've met
some people who've done some pretty bad
things to people in my life
and one thing i've learned is it's
amazing what people can
convince themselves of or allow
themselves to live with in order for
self-preservation
and that's not a dig it's just you have
to do that in order to get through these
things all you've got to look at
is nazi germany then people in death
camps
now they were postman they were milkman
they were bricklayers
and in butchering and murdering people
in the most horrendous ways
by the thousands by the thousands and
coming out going home every night and
sitting down having a dinner
yeah you can condition anyone because
don't forget
to condition my own firm because a lot
of them were straight goers and when i
got them in there
i mean they didn't mind a bit of
violence but when we was getting into
the organized bit
you had to educate them like if you were
going on a bit of work you can't take a
drink
we lock up in a hotel no drugs no drink
i wouldn't work with them
and so you have to if you like very much
like a paedophile grooms a child
we're grooming people into a profession
and that profession is what's going to
earn the money but it's also the
profession
that could get them killed and what we
used to say
old saying i used to say to him because
i was going you know money and
what do i say don't forget this one day
we're going to get nicked
a little beverages we've got to get
nicked because they ain't going to let
us take too many liberties they're going
to come on us
and we're all going to get nicked so if
you eat the meal
you pick up the bill so don't go crying
when you get knit
so hide your money away do it right
invest it somewhere
don't just drive around in flash guys
spunking out the wall
because when you're sitting in that cell
and you say to your pals outside look at
my old woman
they really gonna you know because you
know make the 15 years
so that's one thing i found quite
interesting is you're a boss of your own
crew yeah
how psychologically did did you find
that you had to manipulate people
and and or was it just as simple as
intimidation with these guys
no no no they subscribed to it what i
would do brian
i would tell him exactly i never lied to
him you tell one lie you've got to tell
a thousand to cover that one and you get
sussed out
and they won't have no faith in you so
you tell them exactly what it's about
what the outcomes can be right what the
rewards are what the downside it's like
swot analysis
strengths weaknesses opportunities
threats so you go through a swot
analysis room
of the business right then if they want
to subscribe to it they can't say
i didn't know you didn't tell me yeah
all right not surprising and also
what we did is when other firms into it
but i made sure i'd done it
every time we earned money i split up
equal so there was no jealousy no one
could say
he got more than me he got more get a
bad taste than that and shop yeah
so they all got the same so when we got
the bird i mean i've got the most
being edward fern and that's where i
i've got the young
really with the twins with the crows
because if you're the governor
we had an old saying well you know i
made an old say
better one goal than all you go so if it
comes on top
i take it you get out they were doing
money look at me while i'm away
like that was my philosophy in my head
but when they got nicked i was trying to
get people to take the rap from
and we'd take the fraud you take the
murders if you're going
you know you're running a third the buck
stops here
right and that's where you so um how
so in terms of the timeline here yeah
when you're dealing with the triads and
all of that how old would you say you
would have been at that point i was in
my 20th
right and how long was it before
you did get locked up well i've got the
seven and off from the main store
went away come out was that was that not
far after that the triads that you wish
yeah yeah
all right well come out here and
was that when you met the cruise no the
second time i
i met the craze when i was 16 in the old
bayley that was up for the murders and i
was up for the armed robbery with a sign
off
how about how old were they uh they were
in their 30s i mean they were in their
prime sort of thing
and um can you tell us a little bit
about that because i know people there's
there's a mystique about the craze
there's something about them
i guess it's the fact that they're twins
and they were gangsters and all that but
what were they like very well dressed
even in the old bailey you know
i didn't know what i was at first and uh
they come out their cells
because they was all up on troll for the
murders and all that and we was on
in the old bayley the old old bailey and
uh
it was ronnie craig went me what are you
doing here
i went armed robbery he went and went
with someone off
and he went you cheeky little bastard
you been we'd probably be seeing a lot
of you and i went
you probably will right forgot about it
and a couple of the screws on the
landing well you know that is
you said that's the craigslist you hear
the names but
i'd never met him i didn't know nothing
but one thing i will give him and i
would never let anyone take it away from
him
um ronnie was in somerset house free
because he was off his rocker
he was not a well boy reggie was in
pockets with us but
when my mum got leukemia they sent her
bouquet of flowers
you know did a thing about mums they
looked after
you know your mum while he was away you
know if they
if someone like family was having on our
time
they'd put a few quid out but they never
unknown money as feelings really they
was going out every night trying to earn
a few quid
where charlie richardson was were i mean
mine's in south africa
and that's why they was jealous of
charlie right
because of the money he had more money
than anyone and they was going to go out
every night
basically robin thieves as well if
you've done an armed robbery does come
on the banner and go like we want a
piece of
action um and i think they had a problem
like ronnie was outwardly
gay right reggie was a closet
right and was marrying people never
having sex with him but marrying him for
a friend yeah that was the rumor about
his missus and then there was
a lot of uh strange rumors about her
death yeah yeah yeah you know and no one
to this day
knows whether she did top herself or
whether one of them done it
but um you know poor girl she got mixed
up in saints hope yeah
she was beautiful as well she was but
you know
it's hard work because when you've got a
girlfriend i had one really lovely girl
come from a really good family
and um she didn't know what i don't live
in she
just knew i dressed very well and had a
lot of money and i was very polite
you know even kate aidy when she met me
she said he's a very gentleman because i
pulled chairs out
and i'm doors for ladies you know i'm
not a rude person
and she said to me she went um you know
how'd you earn your money
and i thought [__] you know how do i
explain her you know all right
she went because i want to take and meet
my mum and dad
she lived in stoke new england
now we was we was putting the arm on
publicans over there
i was taking money off of them and this
is how you come on top she got
the wind of what he was up to um
because my poor sister was singing in
the pub she just like
sing for the all the old girls like
family pubs and i walked in when it all
went quiet
and my sister went what's it all about i
went i saw i said i've just come to see
the governor you know
and have a drink i mean bit of them and
taking the envelope you know it was
quite nice
but she went what'd you do for a living
and i said well i'm sort of liking
banking
and she went oh you work in a bank i
went often yeah
yeah and so well what are you going to
say
you know so i said you know
i'm in sort of like the banking business
so i don't know what she said to her
parents
but they the brother used to use the
pubs and the family name
was getting bigger and bigger and bigger
and he said to her he said you know this
this family against us they're all
gangsters the family you know
and she went no yeah he works in a bank
he went yeah he does you know like
he said go out with him and she come out
with me
and she said to me
you don't pay for the meals i said we
got an account here
i mean you have to live that life you
know you she's a straight go
and i really did like her i didn't even
touch her up you know i liked her that
much you know
she's a very respectful girl and i
showed respect
and uh when it went on and i've done the
murder and that sort of thing she
thought
[__] you know because that was all i was
in place and then it come out i'd come
out
there and within four weeks have come
now i'm nicked for about his banks for
his cottage
like i've got enough guilty on that
because i didn't do it you know
of course right and um oh bill really at
the end of that you know i thought i got
off for that one and uh
that's when i was targeted i think they
thought no you're taking to piss now
and um when they come after me and this
is what these kids don't understand
they're walking around they're pulling
guns out and waving them about
no no no you've got to have such a low
profile
that you know people don't know what
you're doing they can guess
but they don't know what you're doing
and they don't the only people who know
what you're doing are the people you
work with
and this is what you say about the
crates there's lots of these people
going over on the fringes
they hear a rumor same as they did with
me i mean if you believe
after crap that was said about me i've
wiped out after north london you know
it's it's lunacy but
you know the same was for them but what
they did
they capitalized on it and they
instead of putting down them if that's
why they stayed in jail for 30 years
right because they started writing the
books they started glamorizing it
and so what i'm secretary is going to
release them not in a million years the
joke used to be in parker's when
if a guy was never getting out they go
and when's he getting there and i used
to go to choose the art of the craze
you know it was a standing joke they're
never getting out so anyway we we're
there
and this poor girl she's she's looking
and it all comes on top
and when i got out um they went
you're going to get her back because she
stopped she she wrote to me all the way
through my first she was a good
and um i said no i said
i'm i'm going to make them pay for this
they're going to pay
because they come in with my parole and
they went i would put you know your
parole thing i won't kind of stuff it
and they went well i wouldn't stuff it
i've been you don't think i want your
little bit of paper when you keep an eye
on me i said you're gonna pay for this i
said you're gonna pay in cash
i went you got where i'm coming from so
then i took the governor hostage
in the maximum securities and they all
thought i was in that case right
which you know what you can see what you
can see i mean they're making a good
case
yeah but then you look you know what did
you take the governor hostage well
people who's been abused in prison
beaten up in the blocks and now they was
friends of mine when you do jail with
someone
this is what i'm saying the only people
who know what jolly rich have done what
crow's done
what i've done with the people that i've
ever worked for yet or the people who
don't jail with you because when you're
in jail there's no secrets
yeah right you're living with each other
24 7 52
days a week and they know your strengths
and weaknesses and they know the truth
about you
so the only people who can say that the
people who've done bird with you or the
people that
work with you and the people are doing
bird with you are very much like you
anyway so they ain't going to go right
shooting their mouth off
because you could do it on them so
everyone it's a very tight knit
community
so you know you're there and you're
thinking to yourself
right i've got i've got to get out of
here i've got to do it and so when you
get out there you've done all that birds
you know and they kind of go parole and
you [__] that you know
i used to say to him i'm not playing i
know you say oh would you
like will you clean the land or will you
work out your mailbag shots he's got the
[__] off
i'm in jail what are you going to do put
me in jail i'm in the block
right i took the governor hostage that
would be governor hostage
i've created more [__] riots and
sit-downs in your jails and you want
me to sit in front of a problem and i'm
a good boy really you know
it's time to piss out the pro board as
well you know because they're looking at
that file
and they're going this guy's totally
insane you know when i used to exercise
overnight
they used like when i was on the
lockdown they used to have
me walking around at the night time the
ira used to get the same
me moving around with night time and
they used to have a screw on each corner
and two dog anglers and no one would
talk to you and then you'd go back to
the block
even the can you know i couldn't go to
the county you said i write out what i
want and they'd go and get it from the
campaign
and like me dinner in case i attacked
anyone you know it was really crazy when
you got locked up
how did it feel when you because i mean
surely you must have thought
this might be the last you see the
outdoors like do you know
this is going to sound weird right and
i'm not weird but this is going to say
i mean you're not normal thanks a lot
you're excited
about this no no because you look what
i've done later in my life right
anything i do i do it properly myself to
it
right but you know when you're you're
there
and you're looking at it i used to say
i'm not playing
and they go oh like dude it's not i've
done the sit-downs and wound everyone up
because if i went to a prison the first
thing i did my utmost to disrupt it
right so they all had aggravation and so
they come up and they because i'm coming
here to my end of the sentence
and they want to be nice to me now right
because i don't know because i threw
buckets of [__] over them everything you
know
so they they wanna are they worrying
about what you might do when you get out
well they worry about what i'm going to
do now i mean if they go on with a black
eye and they can go there wise yeah we
had a row with reggie craig or a group
of bad
villains you know it sounds romantic but
when you've had a bucket of [__] thrown
over you and no one's gotta wash your
clothes ain't too romantic so that's why
i used to do it with the [__]
like loads of it right over the landing
bounce on the wire and smother them in
it
so i don't go on without on them so i
weren't very popular with them
and so and they knew it was me but
couldn't prove it because i was a bit
cunning because i used to in nimdata
slot buckets
so i'd have two buckets one we loaded up
in the oven i used to have one other
piece and [__] in there because i'm
going to
do it over the landing on them and
everyone hated them so they wanted to do
it
but um when i took the governor hostage
people was getting abused badly brian
down the block been beating
the crap out and i pulled him because
people
people told me bobby what's going on out
you know it's bang out of order
and i had a bit of a reputation for
sit-downs and all that
so i said i'll pull him when he comes in
so he's come on the wing i went here
come here i want to speak to you
you're in a bigger pond i said i want to
speak to you i said come here
so he's come over and i went look what
certainly now they blocked his bang out
of order
i went and we want him back on the wing
i said because he's got a stop
and he went to me think yourself lucky
ain't you i went to what
he said i went you [__] brett and i
grabbed him
there was no talk of hostage right there
was no talk of hostage i didn't saw him
taking him off stage
right everyone's gathered around all the
traps and an ira gets a slipped a blade
in the end
right so i've got a blade he's seen the
blade
he shouted out he's taking me off stage
i think now i'm really into [__] because
you're getting the every mob coming with
the shields i thought
if i let him go they're going to kill me
so i've stuck the blade with his throat
i went look
you've known my record you know i've
done one
yes i went so off it doesn't too many i
went i could do you
i said now you're going to call these
[__] animals off i said then we're
going to sort this out
but i can't let go of him because i know
i let go of him i'm gone
so i'll bring him back to marcel and it
was electric locks in albany
right it was made for terrorism that
that gel got into the door
and i got the wedge because i cut a
little bit um line up out and put a
wedge in the door
i turned him around kicked him up the
ice and shut the door right and wedged
myself in
so that goes on for a couple of days and
i think they will wipe their mouth over
it
the wedge had the door they must have
been spying through the window on me
well i took the wedge out the door
the door's coming through and the screws
lined all up
and i'm going on a lay down and then
when i come back i'm in parkersville
parkers
and you said abandoned ball you enter
here you know
and i thought [__] i've really
done it this time right i didn't expect
to be there without mob
and uh i thought they were gluing the
ticks in there because the only next
stop from
and parkers was broadmoor right
and uh for those who don't know
it's like the worst of the worst it's
well for the lunatics of course it is i
mean
you've got people in everything they're
napoleon and some of them think that
jesus christ might want to nail you up i
mean it's that bad you know they're all
on medication
i mean even richie craig when was in
parker's he used to save a thing called
actor would have called it liquid kosh
right others was getting little tots
like that
he could drink like a cup for the guy
right you know and i looked like that
and i thought he's burning his brain
cells away you know
but he was like a kid not like a silly
kid he like he was into this thing like
he wanted a gang around him all the time
and they talked about
setting up a mafia in england and other
people was going to
[__] do that we're earning our own
money we didn't want to be involved in
organized cri
our own organized crime yeah but yeah
this this
he'd watch a film and he'd he saw the
films like
cosmonauts and he wanted to do that for
real i don't got to be off your rocker
if you're thinking that
so anyway it happened that
we went through one of my pals got
stabbed to death over an onion argument
over an onions
cooking spaghetti bolognaise because we
used to cook our own food because we was
always worried about what he was putting
in our food
because you can get a bag of sugar you
should have two bags
one you put on display and one you died
if you took sugar in your tea
because you'd get someone to grind a
light bulb down put the broken glass in
the sugar and it ripped your stomach to
pieces
so there's many ways to kill someone in
jail or you like the ira did
with the governor they've got a six inch
nap nailed it down soaked in excrement
stabbed him he thought he just got
little puncher wound blood poisoning
straight away and he killed him
so there's many ways that if you want to
take someone out even in there
and you can't get away in there it's not
as though you can jump on a
jump in the car and drive up north or
drive no you are locked in
serious psychopaths and also some very
clever people
so that's where the respect thing comes
in you're always nice to people
how do you stay sane in that sort of
environment because he sounds like he
sounds like he had quite a good read on
the situation right
well it was charlie richardson and
that's why i speak so early of him you
know
he really had a brain and he met you
know you get lunatics in there talking
about how you dispose of a body and all
that sort of thing
and you can't hear that so much or the
next job they're going to do when they
get out and you look at them when you're
thinking you're 60 years of age you
ain't got another life center you know a
sentence in you
you'd be lucky if you you know you get
out of here and you've got a zimmer
frame
so yeah now you know you've got to be
realistic it's it's a nasty little bit
some people just need that sort of
reaction yeah yeah so you're sitting
there and
he's talking all about mining we're
talking about philosophy and he went i
mean you got a brain
you mean what you're doing you've got a
brain you went a lot of these in there
can't help yourself you know we got
people in there have murdered their kids
all sorts of crazy people in there
he said you've got a brain he went why
don't you use the brain he said because
if you go out here and do what you're
doing again
two ways you're gonna well freeway
you're gonna end up he said
either the old bill gonna shoot you dead
another firm gonna shoot you dead
or you're gonna do life imprisonment and
never come out he said but if you do the
education
you can run a business so i got into the
open university
i started studying them best fit it was
it was
education that liberated me from crime
because i thought i could earn money
straight you know and when i went
when i went in to see the psychiatrist
and he said i think you're one of the
most dangerous man in britain
he said and uh you you've got a
anti-social behavior order and all these
labels and i thought yeah and you're the
same guy was caught in parkhurst woods
running around naked with your poodle
right and [__] diagnose yourself as
like having a breakdown and he was he
was meeting people like the ripper brady
all that fun
yeah right [__] that is a fruitcake
the guy right
and uh it was all over a month by hour
anyway
yeah i was borrowing uh an apple on the
table and off
he went there and i thought it was a
test you know and i thought myself
being like too much of a thinker i
thought if i eat the mars bar
it's sweet and it's all that right but
the apple is the garden of eden
right and he's looking seeing if i'm
satan
right so i thought i'll eat the marswal
i didn't know this [__] lunch
right no he's coming in he's gone
what are you doing just just social
psychopathy hit the bell when i'm
cutting it off
and that all that like on the record and
it stayed with me all through my
sentence
because i used to stay in mars bar you
know it was it was a crazy well please
believe me and i was
i was surrounded by lunatics i'm you
know it must have affected me badly my
man is social and all
right but you sit there and you look
what's going on so you go into the open
university
and i really loved it i've got the
learning bug and i was talking to
charlie more and more
and i when this is good and we talk
about philosophy sociology psychology
you know that's what i was doing it
but he'd give me books and he used to
have an air but he used to cut cuttings
out of paper like and it'd be like the
stocks and shares and all that he didn't
only do it we've done it with a couple
of other people who fought out of brain
and we used to have what we call a loon
knight
and me and him and everyone thought
meaning was a bit weird bit sick right
because we got the really bizarre nazis
and we used to get me and give him a cup
so you can get them to tell us about
their crimes i'll say charlie i'm in
this [__] sickback
that was can i just say it everyone
watching you know when people sit and
watch like the
crime documentaries now on netflix
they're going back
through guys should we try their
child killers tonight or should we go
for the people who killed our own mother
let's go
let's go for episode five i'll kill this
yeah but it was one and they used to
come in
and charlie because he knew him all he'd
been in there longer than mate and he's
going you've got to listen to this one
and right it's like putting a tape in
the tape player in this place
i love that you've got to listen to this
and you go
don't tell bobby about your really sad
story you know what's it and the most
horrific thing like someone's like
chopped their mother up and right away
i'm really some bizarre stuff
and it was once that and i thought first
i thought he was winding me up
and we got this one come in and he went
uh
he said he needs to borrow cut it quick
because i was the banker i used to lend
him money out in there
and uh he said then tell bobby about
what happened
last night so i went out last night last
night he went well you've got to lend
him a fiver
he said because they want to go and get
a bit of puff because in the united
states
[__] what he does but i want not 10
percent interest
baxter wish to buy the campaigns off him
so we live well
and um he's coming skeeter and this is
okay
he said well he said obviously never a
cup of tea right
with charlie or the other end of the
table and this lunatic and his mate
there
and even an angel come in myself
i went through what he went an angel
current i said i went you i said what
you want
i said you're taking it he went no i
said well what's this angel look like
then you said
they had big wings and bronze feet and
fire coming out of them
i went you're taking up saying you know
i said yeah i'm gonna laugh with me or
what and i'm getting a bit angry like i
think he's coming he'll call me out of a
fight
the other lunatic next we went no he
ain't because i saw it as well yeah
brilliant
and i went give him his fiverr and
charlie went
ain't the best one we got another one
coming and we used to do it on a
thursday night because it was boring
thursday so we said balloon night on the
thursday night we'll have to ain't quite
and we'd have
the entertainment there did they know it
was called loom night no no that was me
and charlie yeah
they used to think that five o'clock
every single
he used to say you know bobby's studying
psychology and sociology so
he'd like to know all the ins and outs
some of them even booked their debts in
where they chop people up and
put an head in a in the basket yeah
we should get them to do our portfolio
yeah it was unbelievable
and so that that sort of thing happened
and then when i got out of prison
um no first off i went to you because
before you come out maximum security you
go into a b
cat and you know so they phase you out
slowly because you've done a lot of
birds so
and they think you're a little bit nuts
anyway right so they send you to these
and i've got a job
as an educationally so basically i sat
in here because they did because i'd
already caused a riot in this prison so
they didn't want no more of it
so give me a nice little job where i
could sit over an education watch all
the television
and read me books which so it's me
and i married a prison librarian i was
who you must know
no i'm with my japanese wife now this is
my first wife
so i married the prison librarian
so she said she like oh she's a
beautiful person i couldn't say a bad
word against that when we
what happened was we we got together she
loved my poetry because i write a lot of
poetry
and that's how i kept my mind see i
didn't have you doing
that a lot of it a lot of it was what
was happening around me
right but i also am where i made it
thursday
this one i call yeah crazy setting us
out
so so we we're sitting and i'll come
out and it was either go back to london
and go back out i mean they pulled the
car out with the rob's west and all that
yeah and then she was outside the door
with a
little flower dress on and come and live
in kent
and i thought i'd i'd already had it in
my head i'd had enough
because if i go out there go i've got
i've got a war with people
and look go back in there or get shot or
whatever what charlie said or
maybe i could do it so i went bird
and i tried to get jobs i mean i was
packing shelves in tesco's the night
time
i couldn't believe it after the life
you've had done from that apartment
shelves yeah but yeah
you know because well we've got a baby
on the way so i thought
no kid of mine is ever going to sit in a
visiting room looking at me over there
no
that ain't going to happen in my life
that was that your first child yeah yeah
it's amazing what um you know having a
baby on the way to do for a man
it's it was the most beautiful thing
that happened in my life you know with
this little flat baby and i loved it
and um everywhere i wouldn't let no one
older i was really
over the top possessive i'm just gonna
i'll carry it for miles you know
and uh i just thought were wrong really
but um
worked hard then like this mug in tesco
is following me around
like with you know the price guns and
you know you've got a 19 year old kid
with a plastic wallet and he thinks he's
like running the show he thinks he's
like donald trump i
remember when i worked i worked in a
morrisons when i was a kid
and there was like obviously i was like
16 and there was 25 year olds who were
like career heads and their managers
where management i'm like
no offense or nothing anyone who works
about but i'm like you're a manager of
morrison's you're not
you're nothing special calm the [__] you
know what i mean
just chill everything's gotta be put on
the shelves don't worry about it that's
their own little firm though isn't it
tesco's you've got the firm morrison's
got a little firm they're all going to
do those yeah exactly we're going to do
those
those guys in that [__] tesco express
i'll have them yes you know i mean our
tomatoes are way cheaper
and what you sent me when um the price
gun you know
and i noticed it's like i'm a small guy
he's giving me the big dog food all the
little birds in there he's giving him
like the crisps
giving me the dog food and all the
evidence and he went he come around
and like showing off in front of the
girls and he went um he knows nothing
about me
because i've got a huge fight i've got a
dodgy i've
got dodgy uh cvs because i made them up
myself so i could get a job because i
tried getting it straight
like to tell lies to get a straight job
no idea
so i opened i opened up loads of these
building companies
that are going to defunct told the
people i worked for them
and so when they sent the mail out it
was redirected to me because my page
powers used to get imposed on me and i'd
write myself a brilliant cd
so i'm working there with this mug under
a pound of wheat i'm learning
right stacking this dog food so i'm not
the obvious stunning
bunny in the world but i've got a
beautiful dog a lovely wife so i'm
trying to do the right thing
i've wiped my mouth that many times my
lips nearly worn out right so
i'm there like that and he's come around
about he went you've got to learn how to
use a prize gun probably
[__] price gun i could show you how
to show you with a real thing
anyway we're in a little bit too fast
it goes bright it goes a little bit too
far it almost becomes like a little bit
of bullying
so he's walking around and he's gone out
in the back whereas where did the
freezer
and i thought [__] you put you in your
place so i've gone out there and i've
got him in the freezer
right and i wouldn't you ever [__] with
me i said see them looks there i'll hang
you up there and i cut your ass with a
butcher's boney knife i went and i'll
cut your eyes out while you're looking
at me now you know where i'm coming from
right now [__] get off my back right
and then i left him
next thing i know all these security
guys he's run up in his office locked
his cell when all these security guys
come if i don't need the premises
they're going to call the old bill now
i've only been out a little while you
know i've got a baby
so i better leave the premises going up
to my wife with me a little packed lunch
and she went your name earlier i thought
i think i've got sack she meant what
happened i went out with dispute at work
right i couldn't
break it won't it dispute it sorry
i'll put you on there and i'll cut your
eyes that way you look at me
so you know that brought back the old
bad feeling in me you know what i mean i
thought i'm trying to go straight i'm on
a mug job
and i'm being intimidated by a mug right
so i thought no i've got to get a better
job than this so i needed to
get myself some more better references
so i've done that again right
and i went up getting some good jobs and
in the end i wound up being a purchasing
manager
for vanguard systems one of the biggest
dutch companies over here are you going
by the
things it's robert cummings i never used
bobby cummings because
i knew now that they had this bloody
internet thing where you can check
people out the last thing i wanted them
to do was try
someone think oh bobby's a nice guy
would type his name you know that come
up no no no no that wasn't gonna happen
so i get these nice jobs and then
it was a probation office come to me and
said um bobby
you know you've got powerful jobs now
and you're running your own companies
because i was running different
companies at the time my own companies
all legal
wouldn't touch anything bank because of
my little girl
so i'm running that and he said will you
volunteer
to help young kids in trouble because
you've been there right and
he was my probation officer well the
parole officer in the nick the last nick
i got from
me and him got on really well he was
dead when my mum died right
so and he was kind to me so you know i
don't forget kindness you know
so anyway i'll do this volunteer thing
for silva associate voluntary
associate voluntary associates and i get
volunteer of the year
and i said you give me the ones that no
one else can handle all right all right
so you supported the real
kids with issues the kids i looked to
them and they're beautiful kids you know
but people feel they're read full of
nonsense and i was reading these books
and thinking crime was great and so i
told them the truth bright you know
i said it ain't that great if it was any
good please believe me i'd still be
doing it and no i'm not
right so i got on well there then i
thought more about it and it played on
my head you know and
i'm hearing people talking to mums where
their kids are going to you know going
way of young offenders institutes and
all that
and i'm sitting i started up the charity
me and my mate with six quid in my
garage and we turned into a national
charity
and uh it was well i was going into
schools colleges is that amazing
no that that was unlock all right but
the thing i've done wrong a lot of
um blue rings you know middle class
people come in
and the trustee is bold and all that and
they i didn't they wanted the right
policies and all that i actually wanted
to deal with my people
because yeah well the thing is brian
it's
my kids that are dying on the streets my
mothers that are crying in those houses
in them slums
and the politicians that are still lying
and that's what i said i said
my kids are crying their mothers are
crying and politicians still lying
they're doing nothing about it
papering up with people who know nothing
about our world
i mean if you want to live know about
poor people
go and live in a poor area right and if
you get a politician i hated the
corruption
right you've got politicians fiddling
their expense accounts with duck ponds
and all that
yeah if a mother on a council estate
fiddled with her benefits to get her kid
a pair of shoes she's doing three months
that's insane isn't it but no it makes
me angry and until you're saying you
know
i was in the earth for lords and this
this is one thing that everyone laughed
at i'm in the house of lords and the
lord can't now
i was a specialist advisor now because
they've seen what i'm doing so your
charity work's got you in a place where
people are now
pointing you out as a guy who can be
asked about this yeah and
i'm doing conferences for the ministry
of justice i'm doing motivational
speaking
um we're packing the ass out right and
people are going this this guy does so
this is transformed very quickly yeah
yeah yeah so i'm up there doing that so
i'll go into
i'm on john i'm on the house of commons
atmosphere select committee as a
specialist advisor then i'd do the uh
house of lords
uh evidence for education because i've
always pushed education is liberation
i've always said that and i want our
kids educated out of
slum areas and that sort of thing right
so i'm there and i had this law come up
and uh
i couldn't believe it what he said to me
he went um bobby i said yeah what's that
he went from where you come from was on
the piece of [__]
from where you come from to where you
are now this is in house of lords i'm
sitting there on this thing and i'm
looking at him
he said how do you feel i said
how do i feel when i felt like you
bastard i went i feel really at home
he said do you i said yeah i've dealt
with gangsters all my life
that guy has never spoke to me ever
since yeah every time he sees me now he
ducks it
and goes because you know the game
that's really going on look you know i
said to someone one day they said you
know about gangsters i said
look look there i are all in there's a
parliament i went
i've never chopped a kid's hand off to
cut rubber out of trees i've never dealt
in slavery
i didn't know people working in the
fields cutting sugar down for me and if
they didn't do put the whip across their
back
i said and i didn't try and sell opium
to the chinese
i went but all them sitting in there
that's their money i said they're all
pimps
that's all the money i went let's not
even get onto why they went to a rocket
yes of course why do they have wars who
earns money out of wards
yeah i'm stealers and inspectors instead
of spending money
on creation and the national health
service and all those things with kids
right they invested in bombs to destroy
us so what sort of psychopaths you've
got in there
and they call me a bad guy i'll tell you
what if we go to women i'm going up with
a few of them i'd look
like well it got me shake hands but we
come in and have a cup of tea
well actually that's kind of what they
did because they give you an ob
that was amazing in itself you know so
how did that come about
well first off i was made a life fellow
at roster site of arts
and um and commerce all right so that
was the first letters behind my name
then because i promoted the open
university so much and i did it at
number 10 down the street and i did it
for our prisons
i was awarded an honorary masters at the
university
um and then
we get this letter come through right
about the obe and i thought first i to
be honest with you george right first of
all
i thought let's cut my powers down and
wind up they're taking the piss
right no this is what i thought right ob
right
so deborah my secretary at the time she
went
now this is real it's called the stamp
set this is a real deal even the
envelopes got the stamp on it
i said phone them up so she finally give
the queen a ring
right so they phoned up the chancellor's
office right
and i said to him look this is robert
bobby cummings here
i said i've just had this letter i said
i think it's a prank
i said done about an oba
and they went no you know we'd like to
put you on the new years old
on this list on 2011. they went will you
accept it
now though i think most politicians have
been
and i wouldn't give them the time of day
i'm a total royalist
well you you're from that euro as well
on your total list so
i went yeah all right i said um of
course i'll accept it you know i'm going
honor
but i'm not allowed to tell anyone i've
got this in september
i'm not that attorney anyone until it
comes out in the new year's honors list
right so everyone sworn to secrecy
we've opened that letter so i go to my
wife
and now i'm married to my wife are you
me the japanese
one because when my adult second
daughter died
it messed my head up i started it in the
bottle
right i didn't want nothing to do i
hated everyone
i was so close to going back to what i
was
that was the first time in my life i was
so close i hated everyone i had a
railway god and i thought why now
why me i'm doing it all right now why me
now why didn't you do this years ago
and what turned me around brian is
my little baby was in a little wicker
basket in the hospital
and i was numb it i've never known pain
like it brought me to my knees i've
never feared nothing in my life i've
i've never felt pain like that well
that's kind of what i picked up from
your story so yeah
i feel like someone who's almost
fearless like hard hard man
brought me to my neighbors and i don't
mind i cried like a baby
you know and i couldn't make sense of it
if this makes sense
and anyone even if you had a child die
anyone who says i know you feel this
absolutely talking nonsense
because that grief is so personal no
it's personal to each one of you
differently
and and so you get you but it feels like
someone's punching your chest and rip
your arm out that's how it feels like
so i go through the hospital and i come
up the stairs
and i have to go through the intensive
care baby unit because the hospital's
shut down so i'll go for it and there's
the mums and dads with their little
babies
because i kept saying why me why me you
know because you don't expect it to
happen it happens to other people it
never happens to you you read it in the
paper yeah that's it
and uh i walked when i see these these
mums and dads sitting with their little
babies knowing these cubicle things
and they're really weirding that and i
thought why not me i wouldn't wish this
on anyone else
i really wouldn't wish it on anyone else
and it seemed like saint was lifted and
i go into the chapel
and then the priest comes in
and he went do you want to kneel down on
pro you know the thing is i could smell
bills on his breath
i got my baby and i went i tell you what
you [__] off or i know you up like your
governor i went you got me i went i
would really hurt you
and he's gone out the door but i'm
sitting there on my own
right with this little little baby in
this thing
and my head completely went you know
and i come out here and i bought myself
a big bottle of brandy
and i don't know if you've ever tried it
try to get pissed and you can't i think
when you're that emotional
you can't yeah in my life yeah i mean i
haven't experienced anything as
bad as what you've just described but
i've had people die and at that point
yeah you're in that much pain it just
you just want to obliterate yourself
that's right but it don't happen yeah
but i went on like that and it broke up
my marriage in the end you know
and um because i went through a little
white coffin
a lot and many marriages don't survive
you don't survive it
and uh you weren't a drinker really
before that you drank bitter lemon
drunk bit of lemon before that so no i
that's a fib
i started drinking well what happened
was my dad died
and i sat in the hospital with a gun
because the police was looking for me
and the nurse went we got a photo of you
you come in here i was supposed to find
the police i opened up my coach showed a
gun i went
you called the old bill there's going to
be a lot of coppers in the intensive
care unit on a slab downstairs i went on
here with my dad we ain't going to cause
no trouble
and she knew my day she'd got on well
with him so she went well can you put a
gown on so you look like
a patient you know that's so sat here
with a gun on it and be
downed and then sat there for a couple
of days
right and then my mum come and she went
look you boys don't know how to shave
you know you don't know
go home and i'll sit with him and sank
in my head when don't leave him
you know because we sat him in my
brother sat there with him
but she kept on look go on have a shower
and then
we come out and my brother went home in
a pint so i said all right
go have a point got in there he's having
a point and my niece come in she went
he's gone
the old man's gone and that was the
first rocking
that hit me but didn't it be like my
daughter hit me
it's a different thing you're not you're
supposed to
you're supposed to outlive your dad yeah
you're not supposed to know and a lot of
people said that me brian you know
i don't expect to bury my baby exactly
so
that happened and and i think that that
really
i know it's going to sound crazy but i
think knowing that pain that brought
back my humanity
that made me start caring about what
happens to other people's kids what
happens in our community
and all that it it definitely does it
was an experience
i didn't want to hurt people anymore
yeah so when uh when people have died in
my life there was a
person i talked to about this and they
said to me you can go one or two ways
you either go hard and abrasive
or you're almost untouchable anything
yeah or it softens you right off it's
well that someone said to me the other
day
would you ever kill again and um
i said i'd hate to have to do that but
someone obviously
attacked my throat my family i said i
would take
them and free of theirs and he went what
i said i would take them
and through this you had what do you
mean by take or when i was in that
business now exactly what i mean
i said i don't want to mess with anyone
i said i live a lovely life all the
people
around me are beautiful people you know
i married my wife my japanese wife you
know
i mean i took her son on his it's my son
you know
his dad was a roadie kind of he's a
jewelry
that's what i'm saying my wife is the
only japanese bird who talks with jordi
accent
but um it's where children are concerned
i'm very
i've always been soft for kids anyway
they didn't get what they wanted me my
daughter
once she went i was told to go to bed
and a couple of my friends was there and
you know there's still if i think
there's always that little bit of the
iffy of me you know
if i get crossed with people they take
it quite seriously
and and um he said
he said your dad said god bid and she
went my dad
and she went like that now we're talking
about an eight-year-old kid
she went like that the little finger and
joe went away did you see what she just
done i went what's that he went
she went around my little finger i went
yeah i'll make her right
that's this truth you know i never
smacked my child
i don't believe i don't believe in
knocking women about i don't believe in
beating kids you can reason them with
them
you know and there's other ways to
chastise someone without violence
because it's bullying whatever you do
you know and i don't
and i've seen so much of it you know
i've seen people hacked to pieces killed
murdered
and i don't want to see no more of it so
just to
bring this on from the story how did you
meet your japanese wife then
that that is a really weird one now good
i was
sometimes i get called in if people need
to be looked after and they're not sure
if they're going somewhere and you know
it's a bad place
and um so you do a lot of talking that
people do mean
yeah i negotiate with people and um
and i make sure no one gets ripped off
and that sort of thing
or if people are threatening violence on
someone it's sandy having the old
reputation because
i go in now and i'll say it stops now
because you don't want me on your
doorstep that normally ends it you know
so i'm i'm quite happy with that you
know um
but that's a i met you know i was
minding someone and
i met her and she was cheeky i mean
a little bit leery and uh
you couldn't be with anyone boring i
liked her and like we become very good
friends
and and then she was telling me about
her husband and about kai
and that sort of thing and the pain that
they went through
when he lost his dad and she lost her
ass oh so you connected on that i
connected on that
both widows then sorry both widowers
yeah
yeah and well i wouldn't win one because
i had a daughter right
and my wife was still alive and you know
there was no tricky business with me and
my wife we played it straight that's why
she's got a big house right
and you still play it straight now i'll
play it straight now yeah she's got a
big house right
and they all when we got the divorce
they went 11 off the house united's big
house
and they was all shocked when i went it
must lose it i wouldn't know she has to
ask my daughter's life don't change her
life don't change
i said but i wanted off the books of my
company
because in case i did anything i didn't
want or involved in it
and um i said i'll give you the house
and everyone went you met
it's worth a fortune house and i went i
don't care i said you'd always get
things
you know but i'm not going to do it my
daughter's life
in her life for a couple of quid and it
turned out right for me because i went
on and i earned more
some more money and you know i
i look at this way you know you come in
this world and
this is my philosophy you come in this
world with nothing
yeah a separate name you go out with it
with nothing
a name what you do in between that
besides the person you are and i don't
want my daughter or my child
or any of the kids i love and all the
people i love ever walking into a place
where
someone can say he was a rat right they
could never say that
so i talked to myself when she went dad
you've got a lot of letters up when i've
got the oba because
you've got to imagine amy's met me read
all this
terrible stuff about me and her mum
going to uh he's a yakuza
yakusa you know japanese gangsters and
she went knowing mum he's really a
lovely guy you know he's kind to us and
because i used to come over at christmas
so they could go up to the graves there
there's like and he's great with no
flowers on it
and they kind of stay and i used to fill
up big bags of toys for him and all that
you know
do it right for the kids you know i
ain't glad yeah he's lost his dead i
know what it's like to lose
so it was friendship you know and then
i don't know we just got married i
i just said so i said because i'm quite
impulsive
and i said i don't know i said i said
will you marry me and she went well
will you marry me and she went well yeah
i suppose and i said we'll get one all
right don't worry i said you know
i'm a nice person and she went
i don't know about it yeah i mean my mum
and that's when i met her mum
love this person best mother-in-law i've
been
best brother it ready to have that there
right now she's beautiful
she died that's when i even flew out of
japan when i heard she was dying
i flew out they were sacked by her bed i
didn't go nowhere else every morning me
and my life and my guy were there
every dinner time we was there and every
night time before she went to sleep and
we've done that all the time and
she went to me go and see the temples i
said i've seen all that i ain't come
here to see them i've come here to see
you
and i bought her a doll a little one
vagina face
and she loved this doll and when she
died she wanted them to take it won't
matter you know we were very close me
and my mother-in-law
and i had greatest respect for her and
um and so
now my life my daughter said to me she
went daddy you got a lot of letters out
your name i said many years ago i had a
lot of numbers
i said it's a lot better with the
letters yeah and what is your life like
these days
it's peaceful it's it's a bit chaotic
sometimes and
sometimes it's got loads of money
sometimes got none um
i'm very good at getting money i'm not
very good at keeping it yeah
i'll give it away i could identify with
you here i'll give it away
i mean someone on the i mean i'm not a
sucker but
like if a kid wants something like and i
know their family ain't got it and
and they're friends of me you know
because i don't see i don't have friends
anymore
just an extended family like some good
father to all their children
and so if they're going oh like she
needs this for school
i don't say well i'll just go and get it
and
if i want to buy a bit of jewelry like
they've all got crosses
right mm-hmm every one of them got
across my journal must think i'm a
really just crank
because i keep getting crosses for the
babies when they're born
and i always say when i'm not there to
protect you or you will you know
and that's where i am so and i never
forget their birthdays they never forget
to send me on father's day godfather
card and that sort of thing i've got
very close
knit people i don't like lots of people
around me
i'm paranoid about having too many
people close to me
from and that's from the old days
because i didn't know if someone's going
to stick one in me you know
so i like i'd go in my little country
pubs
we have a little bit of dinner i've seen
the week the kids run about and it's
nice for me
and i've got a peaceful life you know
and there's no price on that you know
and that's why it's so important that i
turn these kids away i'll say to them
look mugs take drugs full
course fools carry tools right you're
gonna wind up in a coughing either way
but if you're gonna do that i ain't
telling you not to do it it's like you
not do it
but you can't say when you're banged up
or when you're odd
right i didn't know because i just told
you and also you
realize the grief you live i mean you're
dead you're gone
right you're dead right you won't
believe the grief you leave behind the
other side of that coffin to your mother
and your father and your people who love
you
you want to believe the grief you give
them do you want to give them that
and also tell them that when you get
involved in that business people come
looking for you especially now
you know days you had rules but now they
kick your front door and they won't only
cut you they cut your mum your date your
little sisters and everyone
it's a different ball game now and so i
don't want them doing that when they
could be doing something else
i've got a couple more questions but
then yeah um
one one more start with
if you didn't get fitted up at the start
by that copper
yeah do you think you would have gone
down the road of crime
to be honest you don't i don't because
it weren't in my head
but i would have probably pushed my job
to be the best at it because i think
it's about little people you've got
very big egos to survive you know and
i've got a massive one
and um yeah my ego is seven foot tall
and
maybe five foot wide you know because i
can't just do something i have to be the
best at it
yeah i have to push myself to the limit
and
um i think you know
i would you know i would have done i
would have done well well look at it now
you know i did well in my own businesses
yeah i took a sixth grade charity
and turned into a national charity that
was respected i've been to south africa
i've been to china
you're charlie world famous yeah yeah
and not now
it's i've read about it yeah they are
doing nothing
you know all they're doing is trying to
get an ob i think
but um i look at it and i like japan
or africa i've done africa india you
know if i'd have told the governor of
park earth
that i would be traveling the world
right ireland europe all over the world
talking about how to reduce crime right
now
going back to parker's when i was
banging right and i was going to meet
the queen
and she would give me an obe he would
have sent me straight over to the
psychiatrist and i would have been on
the wally juice right yeah but i've done
all the wrong work
yeah but i've done all that and what i
say to kids no matter how bad it gets
right no matter how bad it gets and no
matter what you've done
you can turn it around if you want or
you can carry on doing what you're doing
but everyone's got a choice and
sometimes it ain't going to work
you know sometimes i've tried things and
then worked out and i've been gay
because i know it would have worked and
it would have done
right by the kids when i wanted to build
that what was it 280
million pound i've got investment to
build a village
a training village now there's a company
in the midlands and this is
this idea it's called phoenix training
midlands now they've got the best record
for forklift
truck driving not all kids want to go at
university right
they do all these other training things
they do actual skills
oh yeah yeah and the guys committed
trevor cox he's totally committed
now he was one of them hanging on
flogging brigades
until he met bowie he come to a
conference where i was doing the talk
and he said i didn't realize the
obstacles ex-offenders are up against
after that the guy i mean he's a
multimillionaire he's turned all the
business around
and he caters for the most disadvantaged
people in our country
and he does it properly he's not there
nick a few quit he's there
make sure and the right up so he gets
ready getting lots of government
contracts now
but that's what you need not o do you
need a pair of trainers
did your mum smack you don't need that
crap
get out of bed do you want a job or what
do you like well i'll give you one thing
before you know you can ask me the next
question aren't we
quite a drug dealer in prison this kid
his father's soul
and it weren't part it was tough it
wasn't every jewelry but
he sold a bit of puff right he goes to
children's
home he comes out he goes back to his
day same area
back to his dead sells northbound winds
up he's in
prison in the end with three years
wrapped around his belt
so i said lebron i said well what you in
for
he said well you know i mean for selling
he said i don't sell powder he was
really
everyone even i only sell god's weed he
was a roster
and i went is that right i said you know
when you get your bitter gear
he said yeah i said do you test it make
sure it's it's not a snide it's good
gear he went yeah i said
quality control i said when you're
looking at selling it did you find out
what area you can get the most out
of he went you know in market research
i said and when you're looking at who's
going to run it for you you picked the
guy you trust the most he said yeah i
said
distribution networking i said you've
got all the skills of a manager
who's just selling the wrong products on
i said if you were selling chanel
you'd be driving a porsche and the old
bill wouldn't keep kicking your door and
at five o'clock in the morning
i said you've got all the brains down
now this is the catch
that was one thing because i used to do
this a lot in different schools and
prisons
getting their potential how can i turn
it into a positive one yeah
i'm going through westminster because
i'm going on one of these meetings the
talk shop you know
we go there one week we talk about slang
[__] how we're going to solve it and
then it goes on for a year and we all
talking flat i hate talk shops
gone there right because that nothing
comes out of them
they said bits of paper right going
along there or something a
bit big look round there's this fan
all right look at that it's in in the
van with a couple of other cases
he meant boy i went hello oh i just
pulled over
he said get in the van get in the van so
we do all right what's going on
it's got leathers on the top of it right
so he said fancy a bit of breakfast
i went yeah i said but you're paying
right so we had a little laugh you know
i would have paid but he didn't even
know no so we're going to have this bit
of breakfast
he there he started up his own winter
cleaning company took on ball what i
said
he went and learned from the bank i
don't know what bank it was but they
taught him how to do books
you know so he goes and learns off this
bank woman
right because i don't know where they
got the first set of letters from i
don't care but they're doing the win to
clean business
he starts building up around then he
employs the pedals come out the neck
so that's another one god straight he's
working with him
they built up quite a nice there's three
of them right when i met him god knows
what he's got now
he went what where is it do you know
what i'm thinking of doing i said what's
that now this is before this all come
out of it he said i'll think of going
into car valeting
so he's used that entrepreneurial skill
that he had he's always
had right for positive things so it
costs
in them days it costs uh what was it
fifty fifty seven thousand four hundred
pound a year to keep a young man in jail
not my security young man in jail right
but he saved this government by then
we're working plus he's paying the tax
over 150 or grand a year at least now if
i could have built that village
right i could have taken all these
people out of jail
put them into training training that
they wanted to do not training i was
making them do because you've got
you've got to give people choice what's
good for one ain't got the owner
and this is what they've got in
everybody doing brian they stick people
in little boxes
and they call it key performance kid
performance indicators kpis
kpt's key performance targets kpis
was invented by um
nuts in the home office right now you
say kp nuts
yeah it's nuts in your own office right
so what you've got to do is look at
these kids and think how can we do it
and there's no good just sitting around
talking in talk shots and getting all
these people
who don't know what they're going
through right they blame it on
every kid now you never heard of people
with like mental health problems because
they don't want to deal with
oh he's hyperactive now he's brought the
tears because a teacher don't know how
to teach him he's made the school boring
mm-hmm
the kid why not have him learn basic
[__] english if he wants to go and do
brick laying plumbing all day
last year pull him out of school put him
on course
yeah i think there's a lot of that that
doesn't go on and it needs to be
it basically looks um it's frustrating
bureaucracy just gets in the way of no i
tell you what right i'll tell you
right say for instance
right now this is where you're going to
think i'm really insane right
i don't think you're insane right take
for instance if crime
ended tomorrow if i found a way saying
like no criminals tomorrow
judges are out of work police are out of
work
solicitors are outward barristers our
probation's outward social workers out
of work
right where's the jobs going to come to
fill themselves
it wasn't just you making a living off
of chrome
this is what i said this is what i said
in the book
right i was in the criminal business i
want a gangster i was in the club
i knew how it was because i watched what
my brief was getting off me
i mean one of the biggest robbers i've
ever made in my life and legal
you know i'll get you out of this bobby
you know i can help you boy you know
you're looking at a big in here
and look at him i think legal robbery
yeah it's a racket of sorts it's in many
ways it's the same similar putting
bricks through your windows and then
saying before well
the thing is and the thing is they're
doing a deal with the old bill anyway
trading off basically yeah they're
trading well you can have him if you let
this one go or
go easy on that and there's a few queen
they're all in the swindle
right so in them days i knew how it was
working
so why should i respect him i've met
some really good coppers
and i've met some really good prison
officers and i've met really good judges
but i've also met the other ones who
aren't and they're worse
they're equivalent to the the criminal
enterprise as we want to call it the
super gracie now
then bank coppers are worse than that
because they disgrace all the other ones
and they see that warrant card there's a
barclay bank card that they can go
around cashing in on
right got no respect for them no respect
for them at all
got respect for the normal copper and
the bait but when you get specialized
squads like
the robbery squad the drug squad and all
that they're seeing all those feelers
earning a lot of dough
and they're thinking i want some of that
i'm going to cut them under well
on maybe 30 60 grand a year these people
are earning that in a month
i think undermines the whole system
ain't gonna be too hard to corrupt them
is it very easy when you've got
as much money as the criminals on me
again yeah it's just slowly it's this
the same as when you're in prison
yeah you know those who ain't got
nothing live on the prison rations those
who are connected and got a few quid
you're eating steak
and that is fact yes and anyone who's
done bird will tell you that
you know you have your own what they
call it your food boat
what are the others are eating oh
there's a bit of dodgy meat we've nicked
the best bit of meat at the kitchen and
we're
here and you know it's like good fellows
in it yeah but that's how it works
business come on bro yeah i've just got
one more question unless you agree
uh i was going to finish on my last
question i guess i was just sort of
wondering what it's like to be around
other dangerous people or people who are
considered to be dangerous because the
way you describe the craze or
um charlie you sound
not affectionate towards them but it
sounds very familiar no
to be honest yeah yeah i am affectionate
towards it because i also see their
suffering
you bang out listen i've done a lot of
bad things in my i've never banged
someone up in a concrete box and told
you them for 30 years
that is sick right nothing's done with
them it's the same as charlie bronson
that guy ain't killed no one you've got
pedophiles and rapists getting out
before
him and they're banging that guy up it's
been it's doing a crime against humanity
i don't know what is he ain't even
killed anyone
you know at least i had a crazy ad
charlian charlie got 25 years for gbh
but the real story today was he was a
political prisoner because he bugged
daryl wilson's office
that's what all that was about that was
political move really
go and look through any criminal records
you find me anyone else who's got 25
years for gbh he won't even in the
country was in south africa
what was it like being in london at that
time because it sounds a lot like you
can't go to
so for instance after you've had your
problem with the triads could you then
go to that part of town or would you
stay away from those
areas i didn't give a monkeys about
anyone right
look you know i think what made me
survival is because i'm so
little you know and so when you're up
against nicely big people
right you've got to have the edge and
nothing greater than each
than ever at all so it makes you more
violent
because you think i've got to take this
person out seriously otherwise he's
going to take me out
and so it's a really vicious circle
you're caught up in
and so over the fitness in there yeah
and so like and you've got to
imagine as well in them days the ippy
thing was coming around so there was a
free love
which was quite nice um and that was all
like going around with flowers in area
which meant good
because why they're not out doing
villainy and they're all sitting there
peace and love i'm out getting a few
quid
so you know you're happy those [__]
are asleep yeah london was very
different then though
like that was it was very different to
what it is now there was i tell you what
there was characters in london like guys
it was coy and there was the only
there was angel guys that were all good
everyone goes back to themselves
lovely guys you know what ma'am really
good guys i mean nick and all right
i i've i've met people who know that
healthy angels very i've obviously be a
diver with one of the hell's angels and
uh
didn't describe them what you have to do
yeah
no look lovely if you if you missed with
it because
they had their own rules their chapters
and all that and they've done each other
look seamless like we were doing we're
doing
each other they had their own society we
head outs but you look at what they've
done
they're running on motherboards blood
banks you know
the guys this is what i'm saying you
label someone and everyone goes that's
him
you're there can you know the guy until
you've met him and you've been yeah
before the fella who i was diving with
was a really nice guy to be fair i
suppose it depends on the context that
you
you take people in though because uh
everyone is capable of bad things if you
put them in a situation where that's
what they have to do
everyone is he was a nice guy at you
it's like i'm nice to people that are
nice to me so you was nice to him he was
nice to you
and so you respected him he respected
your responsibility
angels when you hear there's a great
series on a while ago
describing some of the things that they
did um
i mean they were making meth and stuff
like that from what i remember
just vicious the way they would end
people like
what it was until you're saying i could
take you now because when i was out in
south africa i was in cape town
because i was meeting the anc yeah right
and uh because i look in their jails
i was sponsored by a law firm to go out
there and have a look what was going
down
but and the law firm represented the anc
so i was out there and so
it was their terrorists then there i
called judges the anc right
so i'm staying calling my south african
family
he was supposed to be a bomber she was
like a terrorist now she's an i call
judge and he's a
top human rights lawyer so i'll stay
with him when i go over there
and i'm going to shanty town and we meet
people living in
concrete well metal shacks really
and what happens is you've got the uh
like i think
it's like from mexico
places like that going in there and they
take over their place
do the crystal meth right
they go and do the authorities they're
gone with the gear
but they got the kids addicted to it
you've got more aids and prostitution
out there young prostitution
because when they're making it they're
looking them up on it
and all the jails are full of these
young kids that have been runners from
done that and that's why when you're
talking about stuff like that the
heroine
crystal meth you know that kid don't
know what he's doing
you're not just destroying that kid
you're destroying the whole of his
family
the grief that's left behind that's why
when dealing that business i refuse to
deal in it
in in drugs in general i i made a rule i
don't deal in fuel for done dealing
porgraphy
pimping people slavery and i don't deal
in drugs
you knew i'm dealing in gambling or
dealing with money lending and i'll deal
in anything else
but you were you were running alongside
a lot of people at that time
but that's their business yeah look in
the morning
right and you know this one right when i
was working
what i was doing i was getting in the
morning and i had an angry face and i
didn't like the world
i'd get up in the morning i like me now
right
i like me now i couldn't say that to you
before
i didn't i didn't give a [__] about
anything you know i really didn't
but i actually liked me now and i love
you quite a dramatic change in your life
yeah you've been on a hell of a ride
yeah
and it ain't stopped yet no thank god
man
what's your experience been like because
you've got to travel to all these
different countries
do you see a similar system in each of
these countries
it's much the same maybe you've got
those who've got
those in the middle we want to be the
guys at the top
and the poor bugger down the bottom who
just wants a meal
right so no it's no different anywhere
same in japan as well in japan it's it's
very cunning in japan because it's
very kept under wraps you've got the
yakuza the yakuza deal with yakuza
and you might find out that someone's
killed and it's the yakuza killing
but you could go there your wife could
stand out on the street
right three o'clock in the morning no
one go near no one molester
right you don't see the police they're
ridden and i stood in when i was in
osaka i stood in it once one night
and i was thinking where do i want to go
i want to go and every drink where do i
want to go and i stood there for about
five
straight away cut it well come out when
are you all right sir you know you lost
you will
take you back to your hotel i went nice
all right olivia you know
and i'm gonna have a drink all right
then you know and then they vanish again
they've got um special coaches on trains
for nervous women
right right you your guard walks along
the train with a white glove on
strokes the seat and if there's do it on
that the cleaners are on the next next
there's a lot of respect the kids get up
if you're in there
you're a guest to their country they get
up and they offer you a seat
so even the elderly do that you know
it's
totally the crime it's sort of
non-existent i mean there was a big
flash on the television out there and i
said to my car
what's all that about because if we get
a news flash
it's someone murdered someone like
someone out boy it's a big crime thing
it means terrible day i said what's that
you mean that guy on there he said
he got caught smoking drugs in in
college a joint
he's disgraced the whole of the family
the father had to give up his job
tomorrow and moved to a different
prefecture
because the shame it brought on the
family you could blow someone's head off
here
and still live in the same house and
they go will you ain't a bad boy yeah
you know
it's a little bit misguided no one tends
to feel shame here
and especially living in dalston you
hear a lot of stories of
people crossing between areas there was
a girl killed
on thursday stabbed to death in south
london well you look at everyone that
that young girl out
you know with her little mate there's a
bit of gang warfare over i've been a
drugstore machine gunned out and killed
the dead 15 years of age
you know it's crazy you know it's even
crazy in my book
i must admit like coming from newcastle
and london even
even that is a big difference like
like if this isn't this is not a good
place to bring a phone no
you know i've been jewelry land right if
you've got your young boogers you're
going to wind up having punching these
lights out
it's going to end there it's going to be
a light a bit of punch up
so no one might get hurt a little bit
but they ain't driving by shooting
little 15 year old girls it's [__]
disgraceful
you know i'll tell you what you know and
this is what why we cry i'm glad he's in
japan
i'm glad my daughter don't use my name
she uses her mother's name
my just made a name no one knows
my daughter and we agreed on that
because that way if anyone out there
with me
i can't touch my daughter yeah and if
they went there i'd wipe out the old of
their family
all right
um it's been an absolute pleasure thank
you and i
thank you for your time today because i
think we've uh i've learned something
now like i like yourself i like to learn
something um
one last question i'd like to ask you is
how would you like to be remembered
um take your time god that is an odd one
man yeah how would i like
i'd like to be remembered for
my humanity and not my brutality i'd
like to be remembered
for the good things i've done but also
that i someone once said to me do you
regret
the past what you've done and i said no
because if if i didn't have done that i
wouldn't be able to do what i do now
i won't have the credibility to be able
to do what i do now
but no i'd like to be remembered for my
humanity not my brutality
fantastically you've got a book out uh
for those who want to buy it'll be
probably able to search it on amazon
what's it called i'm not a gangster
i'm not going to say and everyone laughs
when they read them
because it's anything um
so we'll put the link for that in the
description below if anyone wants to buy
it and get
even more of your story i'm sure that'll
be there the thing is it's
because i brought another book out part
questions but that's about jail and
the the best book because it with i'm
not going through it it shows you how it
evolves
and how your own children see this is
why i wanted that in schools
and i wanted mums and dads to read it
because it shows you
how your kid can get sucked into that
it's really a book not about well it's a
book about crime and there's some
vicious stuff in it
you know because i have to tell the
truth but really it's a book about
redemption
no matter how bad it gets and what
you've done and i say the kids
you can't do what's worse than i've done
but look what i've done now
and any kid and i you know if i get one
kid
then my life has been worthwhile if i
turn one kid away from that life
because i don't want him to add the life
i had then i don't want no kids about
that
i want him to add the life i've got now
it's pretty cool good for you man not
bad for an old guy you know
yeah plastic tape and i've got every new
one standing in the bottom
um yeah so if you enjoyed this make sure
you hit that like button subscribe for
more podcasts
thanks for watching we'll see you later